thanksgiving essentials are out of stock
cnn's story during the first week of
november whole bird frozen fix weight
turkey were in stock at a rate of 64 on
average across national retailers this
time last year that figure was around 86
availability of packaged pie was roughly
last week compared to 78 in 2020 liquid
gravy with an in stock rate of 73 is
down 12 percent
uh compared to last year and cranberry
sauce would available availability of 79
is down from 89 same time last year
retailers typically like to have around
95 in stock rate overall this year's
stores aren't anywhere close to that a
number of factors are contributing to
thanksgiving staples disappearing from
store shelves including supply chain
ruptures and an unexpected spike in
demand danielle why is this happening
well people look the media has been
going nuts with this so everybody's
saying buy early buy early buy now buy
now buy now
so everybody's shopping for thanksgiving
early so you can't stock the way you did
in prior thanksgivings if you're a big
supermarket chain if people are not
going to buy all the way into next week
if they're freaking out and buying and
hoarding in advance i mean i'm gonna
have to make my own gravy this year
which is fabulous but um
but i was amazed at this at the grocery
store a few nights ago at the sheer
number of empty shelves that i saw
around the store but i did see one area
of the store where it was fully stocked
what's that that was bacon
really well the bacon the bacon's on the
shelf it's not flying off the shelves do
we have a chart to show what's going on
with you we have a chart we have a bacon
chart let's do let's pull that
look at the 2020 price of bacon 5.83
cents a pound on average in 2020. so
you've had a little bit of inflation in
in pork bellies here the last few years
it was a flat decade for bacon mostly
you know what you're right it's from 554
to 583. yeah so when i was at the
grocery store a few nights ago oscar
meyer bacon one pound 9.99
could be quiet nine 99. from 583 to 999
but don't tell saki because you know
inflation doesn't exist
so let me ask you no no economy's
misunderstood too what she said no
economist can go from 583 to 999 and
call it no inflation
here's here's a question for you how
much of this has to do with what's going
on at long beach la how much of this is
that is any of this imported or is this
in the states oh most of this is in the
states okay so this has nothing to do
with what's going on i mean we're not
exactly you know buying turkey or
chinese cranberry sauce that's right no
so that's let's hope not so i will tell
you that that one of the largest pork
producers in america is owned by the
chinese so they're probably enjoying
sticking it to us so i guess the
question becomes is somebody could say
well you know the reason why this is
happening is because so many things are
sitting on the containers where a year
ago was two thousand dollars now it's
twenty five thirty forty thousand
dollars that china is charging but this
is not that so if it isn't that's what
is it then what is it though no it's
panic buying it's people who are
it's it's people who are i mean the
media is all over this and
actually you know what refreshingly
because i i i will say right here now
publicly i am a former bloomberg
columnist as of this week because
uh and i i had been i've been hired by
bloomberg to be uh to be a contrarian
and after biden was elected if i wrote
anything about the economy that was even
perceived as being
remotely negative even though i'm not
writing negative positive or in between
i'm just reporting what's going on
it was rejected by editorials get out of
here so for a long time
it was you know for a long time we've
seen
a lot of of individuals in the media try
and kind of cover up what's going wrong
with this economy all you have to do is
look at biden's approval rating to see
what if you put biden's approval rating
against the rate of inflation it's
pretty damn apparent what's going on
so even bloomberg is now letting stories
against biden go up they weren't against
biden they could be they could be
i i submitted a story that said that
because
you know the state of texas froze solid
that we were going to see plastic prices
increase more and that was going to put
more pressure on producers because they
had to shut down so much capacity and it
took them so long to bring it back
online after the ice mageddon and
they're like
that's a little iffy and i'm like i'm
just saying that there's going to be
problems what's actually happening give
us you know she's saying
she's saying panicked
between now and then is there is an
undeniability you cannot deny
bacon going from 583 last year to 9.99
the media can no longer ignore this
story right that's probably why msnbc is
ranked at the very bottom of the barrel
because they're doing everything that
they can to not report the real news
you know there's something big that's
here i mean right now this is
thanksgiving and america does a good job
of being charitable i mean
you look around america we do a pretty
good job when your local food bank says
we need some help we need some support
and americans will fill that and the biz
doc babe my wife this is the time of
year where we'll buy like we'll do a car
load uh at costco and we'll go the food
bank and we drop it off the food bank
the kind of things that they need that
are long
shelf life things and she was at costco
and she said you know
she says i'm not buying the 6.2 percent
tom i said why she said i know what i
buy and i buy large you know shrink
packs and everything in the food stuffs
and i just paid 440
for this food bank run and it was
normally
you know 360 365. she said that's not
six and a half percent and says and i'm
buying this and i'm buying the staples
that are necessary not just a bunch of
high sodium canned
that's exactly the biz doc babe my wife
because thank you the ladies shall
remain nameless oh this has no name all
right so this is thanksgiving trying to
do nice things buy a car load of
groceries and take it to the food that's
very sweet and noticing that it's not
six point two percent it's like you're
talking bacon from five to nine you know
what you just said is the person that's
feeling the most is the person that's
going and buying the market regularly
and and when you get in a routine of
what you buy you know what you're buying
it's not like you're buying routine
changes dramatically bingo week to week
to week year to year to year unless if
you're having a new baby or newborn
which you guys haven't had that so it's
been a very steady same lifestyle that's
interesting from 360 to 440. so bank of
america came out this morning with fresh
data that shows that if you adjust for
inflation
that grocery shopping in america
over the past year has gone has turned
negative
the amount of groceries that americans
are buying consumption consumption
itself when you adjust it for inflation
has turned negative year over year what
does that mean exactly that means that
they're buying less they're buying less
that's just people buying but here's the
thing you know the whole thought about
the other day i sent something on
twitter uh about the fact that gas
prices are going higher inflation is
this inflation is that i retweeted that
yeah i know you did but they can't
somebody from canada commented and said
well that's because you guys consume too
much you need to consume less here in
canada we're not as we don't consume as
much as you guys consume you guys need
to be more minimalist right so that's
what he's saying well you hear a lot of
politicians today also going behind that
message that rhetoric saying that
americans need to
consume less it's not healthy to do this
it's not healthy to do that so my
question would be how much of this is
planned how much of this is a side
effect of something they did and how
much of it is accidental a lot of it is
too much stimulus
look i was at highland park village so
would you say intentional or would you
say just the side effect of something we
did not know that's going to end there's
a side effect of fiscal spending on
steroids so it wasn't intentional
and fed policy that that's that's gone
straight to the one percent
so i was i was at highland park village
last week the hoity-toities little place
to shop i was going there because i was
going to get one thing on sale at my
little store that still actually remains
there even though it's not chanel
sprinkles cupcakes uh i think sprinkles
is gone
sorry a lot a lot a lot of the lowest
end stores have gone because the rich
have gotten so much richer there were
lines around fendi there were lines
around dior there were lines around
chanel there were lines around hermes
the rolex store opened the day before
sold out in one day lines around the
rolex store even though they had no
merchandise they were just going in to
try and order rolex so i mean if you
think about there's a chart that we've
got that that talks about wealth
disparity can you pull up that chart
please and what the top one percent has
and they're conspicuously consuming and
then you've got some canadians saying
that we should drive less when if you're
the average working joe you have to live
out in the exurbs and commute way in if
you're going to be a bus boy in the
middle of city no questions you can't
afford rent unless you're way the hell
out there so you have to consume more
gas just to get to work and use car
prices or by the way 30 more than that
year over year so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]